بين هذه الجلسه وهذه الحفله رسائل وسياسات
ومواقف كثيره ربما لم تقل صراحه لكنها
حضرت بقوه مواقف صدرت الى الواجهه وابقت
على رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
خلف الكواليس
العلاقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وبكين كانت
تعرضت للتارجح منذ بدء الحرب الاوكرانيه
في حربه على كيف ومنافسا يريد تغيير
النظام العالمي اضافه لكونها منافسا على
مركز التاثير والقياده عالميا عاد
انتهاجها نظاما قمعيا في الداخل الصيني
اتهامات تنفيها بكين بالمقابل لا يريد
الاتحاد الاوروبي التخلي عن الصين في وقت
باتت العلاقات مع الجار موسكو محكومه بشبه
قطيعه الا من انبوب غاز
الصين شريك اقتصادي كبير للاتحاد الاوروبي
صدرت خلال العام الماضي سته ملايين
واربعمائه الف حاويه الى الاسواق
الاوروبيه الى جانب كونها البديل الابرز
للطاقه الروسيه في خطه الاوروبيين
للانتقال الى الطاقه النظيفه واكبر
المؤثرين في قضيه تغير المناخ وبين شد
وجذب واتهام ونفي تقول الانباء نصين كانت
واجهه لكبار قاده اوروبا خلال العام
الاخير اسبان والمان واخيرا الفرنسيون
ومعهم
امر قد يشيل بمن هو اكثر حاجه للاخر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات